c'est venu à calais mal au maire
remerciant d'autres accueillent saluer
d'abord les sauveteurs les gendarmes les
marins tout ce qui contribue encore
maintenant l'hôpital de calais les
agents de la préfecture qui contribue à
gérer malheureusement ce drame ignoble
qui s'est déroulé aujourd'hui ou à notre
connaissance
33 personnes ont chaviré au large de
dunkerque et de calais il y a
aujourd'hui trente et une personnes
mortes ou inanimé et deux rescapés qui
sont actuellement soignés et qui dont
les jours sont malheureusement également
en danger parmi ces 33 morts il y a de
ce que nous en savons cinq femmes et une
petite fille